همم انا هنا مع ضيفتي ندى الحلفاوي ندى
فنانه همم فنانه تصميم من النوبه همم
مشروعها جنوبي مش بس بيختص بالوجه بالنوبه
بيختص بالجنوب الجنوب تقصدي ايه يا ندى
صباح الخير الاول ههه
يا سمر معلش تعطي الضيف المايك هتعملها
بشكل مختلف بشكل اا الناس تقدر تلبسه بشكل
يومي يعني اا وحاولت ان انا اجمع ما بين
الثقافات الجنوب بشكل عام في همم النوبه
السودان وجنوب افريقيا وحاول نعمل ميكس ان
هو يكون بشكل مدن اكثر
همم طيب همم كنت عايزه اكل كده تحكي لي
حكايه بقى يعني هنحكي حكايات شويه عن
التصميمات بتاعتك يعني انا حاسه ان كل
حاجه من دي وراءها قصه حكايه
باحاول اجمع فيها همم كل قطعه باحاول اجمع
فيها الثقافه يعني مثلا في قطعه باحاول
اجمع فيها الثقافه النوبي همم على البيوت
النوبيه الجمل العربيه همم الموتابات اللي
هي لها علاقه بالفلكلور الالوان كمان
الالوان
بشكل يومي دائما اللي الناس بتلبس الحاجات
دي بشكل يومي انا شايفاكي مركزه على
الوجوه همم باحس ان هي بتدي بتدي اللبس
حاجه مختلفه يعني تبقي لابسه حاجه لها
تعبيرات ودايما الوجه بيبقى له تعبيرات
فبحب ان انا ابينها في في الهدوم فتحسي
انسى حاجه مختلفه يعني طيب همم ندى انا
شايفه كمان الديزاينز كلها انت بتبقى ايه
مودرن كلها يعني نستخدمها النهارده البنات
اللي رايحه الجامعه او ال- اللبس كله
بيقدروا يلبسوه هم يعني ناس بتشتريه منه
وهو رايحين عادي يروحوا يشتغلوا بيلبسوا
الحاجات دي عادي جدا لان انا باحاول اعمل
الحاجه بشكل اا يقدروا يلبسوه في الوقت
اللي احنا فيه ده عادي في اي وقت مش مش
لازم في المناسبه معينه او في وقت معين
يعني يعني الديزاين جاء نوبي لكن
اللبس نفسه همم عصري بالضبط بالضبط بس اهم
حاجه ان هو يحس ان هو مختلف هو لابس
الحاجه القطعه نفسها يحس ان هو لابس حاجه
مختلفه انا شايفه كمان في حاجات انت انت
بتشتغلي على ورقيات وعلى بالضبط
فبحيث ان ت- يعني يبقى الفن ما نقول في
اكثر من منتج اا الناس تقدر تستخدمه يعني
كراسه بشكل يومي هتقدري تستخدميها وعليها
الهويه اللي لها طابع مختلف يعني
من وجهه نظرك بتميز ال- المجتمع ده
المجتمع الجنوب ايه اكثر حاجه بتحسي انها
هي دي مختلفه همم اكيد طبعا الموتيبات همم
الالوان همم الطريقه المختلفه ال- اللي هي
مرسومه يدوي اللي بتلاقيها دايما في ال-
في البساطه على البيوت النوبيه او او بيوت
في جنوب افريقيا بيستخدموا برده على
البيوت همم
فبيخلوا كل حاجه لها تحس ان هي همم يدويه
او حاجه مع مصنوعه يدوي وفي نفس الوقت
بتبرز الهويه بتاعه كل بلد انت بتصممي
وبتصنعي وكله اه وكل التصميمات دي بتبقى
همم مخصوص باعملها مخصوص لجنوبي همم
والتنفيذ بتاعي برده بيبقى من خلالي انا
فالمنتج بيبقى 100% طالع من عندي وانا
اللي بصنعه من البدايه لحد المنتج ما يبقى
بشكل نهائي
مين اكثر ناس بتقبل على التصميمات دي يعني
ههه شباب بنات همم اسود شباب ولا كبار في
السن ولا ناس عندهم نفس الهويه او ال- اا
معظم اللي بيشتروا من عندي كانوا في الاول
كانوا في الاعمار ما بين 20 و30 سنه
دلوقتي بقى في ناس بتجيء لي لحد 60 سنه
بيلبسوا الحاجات دي ويبقوا مبسوطين جدا هم
لابسينها وما بيحسش ان هم لابسين حاجه
مختلفه لا بيحسوا ان هم لابسين حاجه همم
لها طابع وفي نفس الوقت اا مناسبه للعمار
مختلفه يعني همم انت بتصممي ازاي انت
بترسمي وب همم
البدايه عندي بتبقى فكره همم بتتعمل على
اسكتش وبعد كده بابتدي ارسمها على ال- همم
على الجرافيك تابلت وبعدين بابتدي اصممها
بشكل ان هي تبقى على القماش همم وبعدين
بابتدي بقى اعمل القطعه بتاعتي كموديل
وبعدين كتقفيل بيبقى لها اكثر من 10 خطوات
عشان تطلع هي ال-
همم شكرا جدا يعني يا ندى وهمم يعني يا رب
تبقى زي يعني الشعر الكبير عبد الرحمن
الابنودي الله يرحمه والفنان الكبير محمد
منير نقلوا فنهم هم من الجنوب نقلوا لي
الابعد ما يكون للعالم يا رب انت ان شاء
الله كمان تقدري تنقلي فنك لكل العالم
باذن الله شكرا شكرا سمر واكيد الفن
النوبي لمسنا ايضا كغير مصريين وغير
نوبيين شكرا لكما من القاهره مراسله صباح
العربيه